don't forget to get dress you guys are
naked uh we're not naked it's called
being naked what's you know the lethal
terminology uh whatever I like the
normal jumpsuit do we not have the the
emote mod on here uh it's a different
one so there's a Tilda emote and as you
play you unlock holy sweet Jesus it gets
a lot there's like nine pages of them
the way you get more is you go to the
terminal and you type emotes and it has
its own currency so if you buy emotes
you're not spending money that we can
spend on anything else you can buy more
emotes at this terminal here oh my God
you also third person camera when you
emote now nice it's beautiful what a
time to be alive there we go now we've
got one you can scroll wheel to page two
and you'll have boogie down all
[Music]
right you guys want to go to a new
place yeah I guess that always turns out
good for us World okay well what doesn't
make any sense Minecraft world it's
lethal company it's Minecraft world and
we're going there now and you kids have
to pull the lever cuz I can't oh
okay yeah love is that cuz of the no
just always the very first day the host
has to pull the lever then after that
anybody can pull it oh so it's a fake
it's a fake responsibility that's
granted up to me it's it's actually a
Minecraft
world
hazard level M M for
Minecraft all right I'm going to um get
a oh right yeah that's
important well this ladder is kind of
high
up I don't know if we're going to be
able to get heavy things I screwed up I
didn't disable the walking mod I swear I
did but I still have it in my walkie oh
no oh
no oh no is it the same like creatures
even though we're in Minecraft land or
is it a whole thing uh there is it is
the same creatures but there is
different
loot different loot
huh how do you know where to go I think
you're on to something I'm going this
way yeah I like this way right way yeah
this is the right
way wow feels so right going the wrong
way
Wade I'm right behind you an
idiot I hope that voice uh clip gets put
into a
monster I'm right behind you okay well
this doesn't seem like
anything no no no just wait just wait
just wait is this real water wait wow
that probably would have killed me if it
was all right hey wait where are we
supposed to go that way how do you know
I was really hoping there would be like
a villager who would haul at
us
oh just get your voice clips
in oh
oh oh you don't upstairs
automatically [__]
unplayable the hell kind of
terrible I'm going
in hey wait a minute hey this is
familiar Minecraft
villager oh look at this guy oh he
helmed yeah do it
again
[Applause]
what are you doing to that guy
what hey I don't like where he up when
you throw him down yeah WHYY keep
putting his head between your legs oh
you know how things be oh is that a
spider Under the Stairs yeah what is
that what am I looking at uh wait it's
Steve yeah hey no
wa this place is weird look look hey
Mark look mark look mark look look Mark
uh-huh yeah I'm
looking Mark he doesn't make a sound I'm
a little disappointed
uhuh oh there's a chest yeah I don't
know about
that that seems valuable it probably
is
oh does this blow up God I hope this
doesn't blow up Mark you got to use the
walking Mark God I hope this doesn't
blow up I'm going to take some stuff
back before you all die
Oh Hey Jake and I are hanging out in the
kitchen
Jak Jake I don't like the way this uh B
sounds well maybe he doesn't like the
way you sound think about that there's
like some offbrand
Minecraft music outside I don't like it
I'm full up Jake I'm going to head to
the
[Music]
door okay stuff dropped off coming back
in not seeing a lot of hostility CU
there supposed to be something to be
concerned about out
here
can you repeat that we were busy a
spider
who uh check how y'all doing what's uh
going
on not sure how we're doing there's some
horrible
noises n we're
fine all right well I'm just going to
run back and keep getting stuff to the
ship so we can have money time check
540 hey there's a locked door here I
know we have some keys uh there's a key
by the front door also there's some goop
and also there's a Mr Krabs voice and I
don't know what that means uh can you
repeat did you say Mr Krab's voice yeah
I just walked up to a locked door and I
just
heard you guys ever wonder if mods maybe
go too
far uh no just
like Mr Krabs is a bug
apparently Che almost 7:00
FYI all right did something just stole
an item from you yeah it stole an
item uh watch out there's multiple
[Music]
things uh who's currently being
chased uh Bob he stole a loot box
[Music]
item oh no okay
no I was trying to close door behind you
Bob did you trap Bob in
there yes yes I
did oh maybe he doesn't like the way you
sound you ever think about that oh
god um not sure if it was my fault that
he died but I definitely trapped him in
there be aware there's a creature right
by the ship
now oh you don't don't walk upstairs
automatically approach the ship from The
Far Side Far
Side
all right shall we
go yeah yeah we lost the chest and we
lost the Bob ah if only we had a
teleporter yeah it was like I started
hearing B yep there's Bob's voice he's
uh Bob's still with us outside yeah did
you uh did you trap Bob to his death
that might have happened but I feel like
that's an unfair way to organize it uh
verbally what I tried to do was close
the door behind Bob but when Bob jumped
kind of jumped sideways to forward uh
attemp
toly uh-huh
yeah no I I have to say I didn't so I I
thought the bugs were chill unless you
tried to take their stuff usually was
just following him and he he set the
chest down and then he just murdered me
while he tried to yeah well so if you
get too close to his loot Zone it'll
also aggro uh like where he stores his
that's sure that's unfortunate so did I
kill you or was it just you landed in
the Slime I mean let's say you didn't
not kill me so is that better or worse
whatever I'll take it over the I'll take
it no I'll take it no caveats you'll
just take it yeah honestly I I think
I'll just take it all right he's just
going to take it yeah he'll take it h
just going to take it uh to offense We
Go okie dokie oh this is nice tripped
out what happened to the Ryan Reynolds
picture in that one frame before H where
am I help help
help you TR in the corner help help help
help I can't help help I can't move it
help help help help okay now I can thank
you okay help sorry I did
wait but I wanted to go there no I
didn't I wasn't trying to trap Mark I
was trying to ergonom ergonomic niiz our
area uhhuh oh you want to you want to
you want to have it like this so you can
terminal while you're watching the mod
it's a whole it's better it's better
yeah the only problem is if we get the
teleporter you're kind of we don't have
the teleporter I'm going to go I'm I'm
going to
go radio check I'm headed
in uh copy copy uh
uh bald eagle is right behind you and as
you
play nope nope nope nope
nope nope hello man we're just taking a
we're just taking a break you can head
in if you want yeah go in oh
okay he's going to die what what's in
there uh you my voice for me well it was
your voice but I didn't stick around
long enough and the only thing that I
know that throws its voice is the big
wolf outside I don't know what does that
in
there okay nope
y NOP what happened what did that I
don't
know I don't want to know he's he's dead
he's dead that's not the right emotion B
Bob is dead he's dead how is he dead
look go in and look to the left I don't
want to go in and look to the left don't
believe me so go look
oh
boy I'm not dead okay hey Bob you're
messing with it that was just Bob
messing with us I'm grabing you oh my
God oh my
God
wait oh new creature data Wade you uh
you good yeah I'm good uh I I see what
killed Bob yeah all right I'm not
abandoning you I'm going to help you
what do you mean I'm outside you're not
abandoning me you're going to help
me ah okay all right oh hey hey hi shall
we uh so uh a turret it was a turret and
a fart lizard that's all that was saw
there oh okay is that that sounds bad
but the way you're saying it makes it
sound not bad well turrets are bad fart
lizards are scary but they usually just
hard interesting well Bob is starting to
stink up yeah you want to take a back to
the ship yeah I'll take him back to the
ship you want me to guide you yeah yeah
I'll leave some computer assistance all
right listen Bob I don't want you to
feel bad about this death comes for us
all we all will meet an untimely demise
but so long as we work for the company
with all our heart and soul we we too
can remember we are a part of a greater
hole you like that don't you being part
of a how do I get back lot of flies a
lot of
flies okay oh there you go saam
okay all right there's a lot of turrets
do you see any loot I should go toward
there's not a bit of loot around you
okay you got a turret coming up on uh no
you're good you're good down that
hallway but if you go right and right
there's a
turret okay so don't go
right
mhm yeah nothing nothing nothing ahead
you seem to be good
straight one piece of loot in
[Music]
there whole lot of nothing yep I'm
seeing the nothing nothing it is
basically nothing but
nothing you got enemies creeping up on
you down that hallway to the right
there's
enemies okay you're coming up on a
turret be
careful No Loot down that hallway might
be dead end I'm not sure
I have a
staircase many loots in the room
ahead no enemies many loots uh a few of
these are two-handed can't grab them all
uh it's unfortunate how many more loots
are there just the one uh no just like
science I'm pretty sure they
can
be advised there's now a mimic by the
ship
somewhere I'm going to head back because
it's after 6:00
then yeah just come back it's not
immediately around the ship it's
probably patrolling that area
outside good enough you think you think
Bob thinks we set him up again like I
didn't set him up last time I but like
it feels like a setup I mean it's I mean
you did say we were on a smoke break and
that he should head inside yeah which
was perfectly safe if he didn't go
anywhere once he went inside you know I
didn't say go
anywhere yeah you're right so like
that's on him
right I'm just waiting for him to roll
in here from the Beyond going uh-huh
uh-huh yeah oh I didn't mean to Boogie
but yeah you know you know hi
hi you know that turret that was inside
to the right through a door yeah yeah
that that one got you that how somehow
activated and killed me through the door
I was standing still in the entryway
assessing the situation assuming that
you had set me up I did not move I got
killed by the turret through the door H
that is very strange cuz it didn't proc
on either one of us I know watch very I
was like oh go inside to die nothing
nothing happen well huh at least we got
money yeah everyone but me did a good
job guys yeah and I did an excellent job
of dying a lot and immediately that's
okay you raised our awareness of the
threats yes yeah I was like the canary
in the everywhere yeah I was I was hyper
aware that something horrible was at the
entrance I just didn't know what or
where also Mark how the hell did you get
out when you were getting my body I
don't know I was watching Wade's
perspective and from our perspective you
were just like that that lizard thing
came out and you were like welcome I
look like oh Mark's dead I don't know
what it was we never saw you get back to
the do it's like you went to get Bob it
looked like you kept going and then you
were like yeah I'm
outside yeah I thought I thought it was
like a joke or something when when you
came on the radio but then you were just
standing outside with my body and I was
like how the look I don't know I heard
noises and I trusted my instincts and I
went outside well apparently it was a
harmless fart lizard whatever the hell
that is I don't know if I've encountered
that yet but it's fine we're fine we're
all it's just not super oh yeah I should
I should all here and we all get equal
credit for all the hard work we we do we
do we really
do I don't like the bees picking up the
bees is uncomfortable I like the bees
it's very it's be are nice this bee yeah
it's kind of nice left your bee out
there a be H this isn't this window
isn't open is it
n hey
con hey KK H I'm honking my annoying
horse oh I see I see Hy
K wait why is it why is it still open
why is it why is it still open okay your
honest work is invaluable the The Thing
Mark
huh why you guys afraid of a
bee I like it wait the one who doesn't
like it I don't know why you so afraid
of bees
wa you know cuz they buzz what does the
100% mean we did we kill oh oh it's
selling at 100% rate if you come here
before the third day or whatever you
sell for Less ah so they don't want you
to come here after each day and just
like making a quick Buck gotcha well
that was a good haul boys it was a good
haul it good work team do we need
anything we don't have flashlights I
need I could use a walkie all right I
bought three walkies and three
flashlights do those come here or do
that at the next
stop right over here
oh and Christmas is over I got to go
bathroom guys I have a resol I have a
resolution for this next move I am not
going to die
first Mark's going to die first okay
your New Year's Revolution don't die
first help me make sure that Mark dies
before I do okay I mean we have sh beat
him to death no no no it has to look
good it has to look good he has to leave
it you know yeah yeah okay like I like I
like your enthusiasm but also I want it
to I want to do it the right way you
know feel you hear me oh I hear you I'm
so I'm just lamenting our bad luck
what's our bad luck is there a bunch of
weather yeah Stormy Titan we could
I don't want to do
aine okay you talk me into it I mean
how how bad could it be you know it's
fair point it's fair point I'm back
hey how's your bladder it's good empty I
just spent $200 in some California
Girls sorry what it's a new
dance is that really where we should be
spending our money uh it's it's its own
currency so I'm not using any of our
money okay good good good good oh snap
hey Mark
[Music]
what
uhhuh what uh-huh
hell what dance is
that I am not a 100% sure oh Mark I can
sink up with you which doesn't look
oh
who dude sink up sink oh my God hang on
uh I don't know where it starts uh there
no just walk up to us and press uh you
find yeah take you we love the company
to the next
level love the the
compy the company theany oh yeah we love
the compy this is the most aggressive
dance I've seen in a hot minute isn't
this from this is from another game but
I mean it's from something else but it's
like this particular style of the
animation I believe is from like one of
those Friday the 13th 4v1 games I swear
I've seen clips of like people of
characters in their underwear doing this
like over Jason's body oh probably
there's a whole website where you watch
people in their underwear dance like
this which one the
Titan
oh boy this place uh it's stormy so
careful with your Metals oh yeah Mark
there's a lot of weather my Metals
hazard level S Plus is that good uh is a
walkie metal your walking and flashlight
are fine okay all right I feel also if
you find a gift don't open it I need I
need to bring a gift back to the ship
for bonus money okay okie dokie an
unopen gift right oh my God
holy crap we're fine are we fine just CL
climb these stairs F randomly strike
sometimes that we might not be fine okay
group up group up for
safety yeah lightning doesn't strike
deadly crowed together humans yeah
absolutely all right I'm going in
who hey I'm alive too seems good so
far Mark yeah what's up I just want you
to know because I'm about to Adventure
forward I'm going to die and I
appreciate you getting my
body nobody panic but there might be a
Freddy Fazbear running around what the
what that sounds fun why would that be
B what
what
what wait are you in the ship
still no do you hear me by chance
I hear you over the radio yeah I just
heard you go hello so I got some loot
not a two pieces that are kind of
valuable in case I die I've got two good
pieces of loot just inside the fire exit
door I don't know where that is wait
yep what's up you hear a chicken yeah I
got a chicken right here
oh okay I oh left man I just I'm
freaking out about nothing over here
yeah I problems we're fine it's fine I
don't know what's got you going so crazy
but keep like I keep dying right off the
rip no no no no
okay well then there's only really one
way to go which is
up wait you were foreshadowing your own
death did it
occur m not yet though I am carrying
TNT I sorry my brain just registered
that you carrying
TNT uh it's
dynamite how do I know if a fire exit is
real touch it yeah no thanks
well I I gave you a factual
answer yeah I mean you're right but I'm
just it's not
real thank you for the heads up yeah
only real one oh like he even
knows he doesn't he how can he possibly
know he hasn't even seen
it all right I'm headed back to the
entrance
I've got a little Mr Crabs bug on my
area here is it possible that he wants
me to drop something that I'm
carrying anything's possible murder you
for something you
have cuz he kind of was coming up in my
area and I didn't like
it oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God the lightning
was like 2 in from my toe
oh my
God oh my
God I'm safe inside right is this TZ a
good idea oh my
God
uh-oh you
hear you have Compu I feel like find a
whole lot of nothing uh we got a whole
bunch of stuff back here uh no I did not
hear someone say hello uh be on the
lookout Wade's hearing voices he might
have heard someone say hello I'm going
to head back in all right all right I
got eyes on you Bob you got nothing
turret coming up
and Bob you still
good yeah I I think the only way I
haven't explored yet has a landmine
blocking it oh wait that's not a turret
that's Lama I can deactivate it here
I'll time it up I'll give you a 3 21 and
it'll be deactivated you can run over it
okay
all
right oh
oh this Sorry God sorry hold on hold on
I couldn't type it oh wow the power's
going out here okay I'm going to uh oh I
can't see
you oh God power this feel safe if you
just deactivated I can tell when it's
not
activ okay it's going to be deactivated
here we
go
should be
good I live oh
dead Mark Mark it's happening
[Music]
mark